HIRSH: Thank you all for coming to today's
Council on Foreign Relations meeting.
The subject is the Great Society, its meaning
and impact.
I think, over the course of modern American
history, there have been two great government
revolutions, if you will, the New Deal and
the Great Society, and a major counter-revolution
and we're still dealing with the implications
of—of all of them.
The Great Society, which was so named by Lyndon
Johnson, first, in a speech he gave at the
University of Michigan in 1964, embraced an
extraordinary number of government programs
that LBJ sought to use to address basically
what he thought were the deficiencies left
over from the Great—from, rather, the New
Deal: Medicaid, Medicare, Head Start programs,
consumer and environmental protections, like
the—the Clean Air Act, the Voting Rights
Act to deal with racial injustice.
It was an extraordinary array of programs
enacted in—in a period of time that was
just as extraordinarily short, by the 89th
Congress, from January '65 to January of '67;
basically that was when most of it was enacted.
And that Congress has been deemed by historians
to have been probably the most productive
in American history.
Grover certainly would—would disagree with
perhaps the term used there.
And then for—you know, for those who doubt
the so-called Great Man theory of history,
I think it's interesting to note that—that
LBJ's idol was FDR, was Franklin Roosevelt.
He went into his accidental presidency, consciously
intending to live up to the ideals, as he
saw it, that FDR had put in place in the New
Deal.
And for a very brief period of time in American
history, LBJ, arguably, had as much power
as FDR did in the very beginning stages of
the New Deal, in terms of the—the vast number
of Democrats that came to Congress and the
impact of the 1964 election, in which an uber-conservative
named Barry Goldwater was—was badly beaten
in the worst landslide in American History,
sending the conservatives for cover for the
same period when many of these programs were
enacted.
But, I mean, just as so many of these programs
continue today, are debated today and, in
fact, I—you know, we're going to lace our
discussion today with the State of the Union
address by the President last night, in which
Obama, you know, kind of, in some respects,
laid out his own vision for addressing deficiencies
left over, as he perceives it, from what hasn't
worked since the Great Society.
But as the—the concept of the Great Society
lives on, so does the backlash, the counter-revolution,
if you will.
We all are somewhat familiar with how it ended,
overspending, Vietnam, the—the disaster
of the late Johnson Presidency, followed by—into
the 1970s, the period of stagflation, all
of which, of course, laid the groundwork for
the Reagan revolution, which is the counter-revolution
I was referring to.
And that way of thinking, right up to the
present day, right up to the Tea Party, is
also a legacy that we're dealing with, even
though Reagan himself failed to roll back
government.
No other Republican president has.
We know Richard Nixon, for example, after
taking over from LBJ, quickly sought the center
and embraced many Great Society programs.
And of course, right up to President George
W. Bush, who not only did not roll back Medicare,
he added prescription drugs to that program.
So in so many respects, despite the rhetoric
of counter-revolution, we have seen a failure
to really roll back the Great Society and
that's one of the things we're going to be
discussing today.
And for that discussion, we could not have
two—a better cast of characters—let me
put it that way, than Governor Howard Dean,
former governor of Vermont, of course, and
former chairman of the Democratic National
Committee, who will be taking the affirmative--no.
And Grover Norquist is president for the Americans
for Tax Reform, but is known to all of us,
perhaps, and has been for many years as what
I would say is the chief scold of the—of
the Republicans and conservatives in Washington,
in terms of—of his attempts to—to continue
to roll back government.
And I—even though what we have here may
be more in the nature of a debate than a typical
CFR discussion, we are going to try to keep
it a discussion as much as possible, rather
than turning it into something that might
foreshadow what we're going to see in the
2016 Presidential campaign.
So, with that, I want to start out.
Governor Dean, perhaps you could just give
us your overall assessment of the impact of
the Great Society then and now and—and how
its—its legacy lingers on.
DEAN: Sure.
This is going to be a hard one to—so you're
going to have to cut me off and I'm not going
to be offended if you do.
HIRSH: I'll (inaudible).
DEAN: So, let me—I actually, now, as part
of my many part-time jobs, teach foreign policy
at Yale at the Jackson Institute, which means
I also have to teach American history, because
a lot of kids don't know a lot about American
history.
And I've learned a lot, just preparing for
the—for the class.
I—I hated Lyndon Johnson.
I was a student in college when he was lying
to us about the Vietnam War.
And I was a fairly low number in the draft.
In fact, I actually had the physical and flunked
it.
And I now believe Lyndon Johnson was one of
the five great presidents in American history,
simply because I judge presidents by what
they achieved and the—and the changes they
made and the changes have been extraordinary.
I also look at this from a sort of a human
evolutionary point of view.
I think, while we all have a libertarian streak,
particularly in America, whether we're Democrats
or Republicans.
We also have a communitarian streak.
And over the last 10,000 years of American
history, I think we've become more - I mean
of—of human history, I think we've become
more communitarian.
So I actually see—see the—the—the Roosevelt,
the New Deal and the Great Society as an evolutionary
movement in the world, because of course it's
happened in other countries as well, which
means we—we actually—it's a—it's a fundamental
difference in philosophy that I think we have
with—with the Republicans and the true libertarians.
I believe that we are recognizing, as human
beings, that we have a responsibility to each
other.
It's not just every person for themselves,
that bald capitalism without rules doesn't
work and that there have to be a set of rules
to make capitalism work.
And the question is then, in the constraints
of what we've agreed to, how do you make it
work.
So I think there never has been a counter-revolution.
There's a lot of talk about the Reagan revolution,
but as Michael pointed out, there's not been
much real change.
And I think—I happen to be fiscally conservative.
Grover would probably disagree with that,
but actually I was—I was once ranked fourth
in the country in terms of fiscal responsibility
when I was governor and they told me they
had to redo the results five times before
they'd release them and I was still number
four in the country in terms of my conservatism.
They couldn't believe it, but I think fiscal
conservativism is actually—is actually compatible
with a—an aspect of responsibility for each
other, 'cause you can't—if you can't fund
the programs, you shouldn't have them and
you eventually have to cut them.
So I do think Johnson transformed society.
I think it was part of an evolutionary transformation
and I think it's for the better.
Now, do we have to fix some of these programs?
Are they going to make us broke?
Yes.
We do have to fix some of these programs.
I am very interested in how we fix them.
I'm not interested in getting rid of them.
I'm not interested in privatizing them.
I'm not interested in turning them back to
the states.
And I think there'll be a lot of discussion
today about what we should do to fix these
programs.
And I will just say, leading into what—whatever
Grover may say in rebuttal, something that
he's probably going to agree with, we—we
cannot continue on the current fiscal course
that we're on.
My view is that we ought to, as Bill Clinton
famously said about welfare, we ought to mend
it and not end it.
HIRSH: Grover?
NORQUIST: Yeah.
You mentioned the two periods of—of—of
government expansion.
It's actually rather tight, the—between
the '34 and '36 election, you saw Social Security
and Aid to Families with Dependent Children.
And between the '64 and '66 election, we saw
the Great Society spending programs, Medicaid
and Medicare.
The federal government right now spends 20
percent of Americans earned this last year.
It was 24 percent before we got the sequester
and wrestled the President on that but not
allowing him to raise taxes up to 24, but
to bring spending down to 20.
But of the 20, half—10 percent of everything
you earn and half of federal spending was
created in two two-year periods, so in four
years of American history.
So when some of our friends on the left talk
about the consensus, if you grab power for
two years at a time and run things through,
you can pass some very consequential legislation
and they did.
In '66, the Republicans won back in a wave
and then in '68 they did.
This—we're supposed to be—we're supposed
to be in the middle of the third wave.
This was Obama's hope that this would be another
period where we jump up government spending
on a permanent basis.
And it's very interesting to watch the different
reaction, both by Republicans and by the general
electorate, after the creation of Obamacare
ACA.
The public remains opposed to it and remains
unhappy with it, would like to see it dramatically
changed, altered, gotten rid of, and it didn't
get a single Republican vote.
Unlike the previous periods where you had
a bipartisan march towards bigger government,
we now have in the Republican Party, post-Reagan
and post-Tea Party, a party committed to,
actually, smaller government.
We didn't have that before, if you watched
eight years of Bush and eight—and four-and-a-half
years of Republican Congresses during the
eight years of Bush's presidency.
During that period, he just kept spending
money, and not spending money and spending
less money wasn't even on the to-do list.
When you talked to the guys there at the 'strategery
group', not spending more money wasn't ever
on the list.
They called—no, they called it the 'strategery
group' themselves, they at least had a sense
of humor, not other things.
On the costs of the Great Society, well, we
spent $20 trillion on—since 1964, in inflation-adjusted
dollars on welfare programs, 17 percent of
personal income in the United States now comes
from means-tested welfare programs, not Social
Security, where you pay in and theoretically
getting something back or Medicare, but where
you just get something because you have low
income with nothing else necessary.
This last year—'12—2012, $700 billion
spent but of course the real challenge is
that we can't afford this very well now and
we certainly can't afford it in the future.
Social Security has a $10.6 trillion unfunded
liability.
That doesn't mean $10.6 trillion owed sometime.
That's the present value of the unfunded liabilities
that we have in Social Security alone.
Medicare, somewhere between $28 and $35 trillion
in unfunded liabilities.
When Medicare was built, the costs in 1990
were 644 percent higher than they said they
were going to be when the government put them
in.
Turns out it's only 150 percent if you adjust
for inflation, so they're only off by 150
percent then.
Looking forward, here's a quote from Paul
Ryan in 2011, talking about the Congressional
Budget Office, run by Democrats.
"The CBO has a model where they measure the
economy going forward and they're telling
us that the entire economy crashes in the
year 2037.
Their computer simulator cannot conceive any
way in which the economy continues, given
the entitlements that we have."
2037.
You can see that.
Some of us may live to see it.
And so when we talk about, you know, was this
a good idea, one, these are the costs, and
then we get—you can have a longer, different
conversation about what the costs were in
human lives and families damaged and neighborhoods
damaged, and what benefits there were or weren't.
And then the other thing to talk about, you
know, is, what else could we have done?
Theoretically, everyone agrees we need to—we
need to change things before we hit the wall
in 2037 or sooner.
Why didn't we do this in 1965?
Why are we waiting till now to do this?
Why six years of Obama saying he wanted to
fix entitlements and nothing?
He just added to entitlements, like Bush.
So that's—as—as you look forward, you
can go through the—the—the costs and the
alternatives as we move forward, because I—I
think we can fix things and I think we will.
HIRSH: I mean, very briefly, before I give
Governor Dean a chance to respond to that,
do you want to just sort of sum up what you
think were the opportunity costs?
And again, we don't talk just purely in economic
numbers here, because this was a program to
transform society specifically to deal with
income and racial divides, education divides,
and a—you know, listening to the President
last night, he—his community college program.
I mean, in a much smaller scale, he's trying
to deal with the same thing.
So could you just briefly address what you
think our country would be like if we hadn't
done the Great Society?
NORQUIST: Well, I'm looking at the seven-minute
speech that LBJ gave when he announced at—at
Ann Harbor the—the Great Society, this is
the same speech that Obama gave last night.
You could take the whole thing without changing
a word, because there are no dates, except
fifty years from now.
He has to be judged on it, by the way, in
fifty years.
And they haven't exactly accomplished what
they wanted to.
It's actually much more aggressive than you
said.
I mean, they've—they've got plans for our
leisure time.
They've got it—they're worried about unbridled
growth in the economy, have to do something
about that.
Love to have growth of any kind, bridled or
not.
I mean this is—we're going to be condemned
to a soulless wealth.
Wealth to start with would be good.
I mean this is just—I mean this is Savonarola.
This is not a guy who just wants to increase
GDP two percent.
This is a guy who's in—in—going to be
in charge of your soul through the government,
but we're going to do it by having working
groups and White House conferences and meetings,
but the solutions to these problems do not
rest on a massive program in Washington.
Really, what part of the thing that they did
wasn't a massive program based out of Washington.
On, you know, damaging?
Well, I passed out a comparison of what happened
when Reagan was president, in terms of workforce
participation.
As the economy grew, more people came back
into the workforce and workforce participation
grew.
As this economy has recovered, workforce participation
has fallen, which is why the only reason the
unemployment numbers are going down is because
of the number of people quitting looking for
work.
If you counted them in, it would be 10 or
11 percent as we move forward.
The cost to the United States we have today—I—I
did pass out this chart.
Poverty was falling up until they passed the
Great Society.
And then, according to the government's own
statistics, static for fifty years or little
higher than it was when they did it.
The Governor wants to argue their statistics
or their definition of poverty (inaudible)
they can.
Those are the government's numbers.
It is not something that was a problem.
It wasn't getting better, it was getting significantly
better rapidly and then it stopped getting
better after they did that.
The number of men who left the workforce as
a result of this program and immediately after,
16 percent of men over twenty were not working
or looking for work in 1965, when they started
passing these bills, it's 28 percent today.
If you look at people between twenty—men
between twenty and sixty-four, six percent
of the civilian, noninstitutionalized men
were out of the workforce when they passed
these laws.
Today it's 17 percent.
The damage done to heads of households, the
damage done in how—what the government has
done there, the lack of progress on the poverty
rate all suggest to me that it—and then
you can track crime and government spending,
crime and the enaction of all these laws and
make your own decisions.
HIRSH: OK.
Well, Governor, a lot of bold claims there,
starting with President Obama as Savonarola.
Maybe you want to...
NORQUIST: Oh, no, no, no, that was LBJ as
Savonarola.
HIRSH: Ah, LBJ...
(CROSSTALK)
HIRSH: Obama's mini-Savonarola.
Go ahead, sir.
DEAN: You know, I—we're speaking a foreign
language here.
What I look at was why Social Security started
and why Medicare started.
When Social Security was started, it was actually
started in the states, because the Depression,
not—as we are not taught in school, did
not start with the 1929 stock market crash.
It started in 1926, when the agriculture markets
began to crash all over the world, not just
in the United States.
And old people, who were surviving on their
farms, because—and they couldn't work anymore,
had nothing and were literally in danger of
starvation.
That's what—Kansas and Nebraska and places
like that is where Social Security started.
What—what Roosevelt did with his 'let's
try—keep trying stuff until something works',
which is basically what he said, is he looked
at other programs and these programs came
from the states and he adopted them and created
a national program for Social Security.
I think Social Security has been incredibly
important, because I think a—a—a minimum
standard of living is important in this country.
We have, in my view, the greatest problem
in this country today, that the greatest threat
to democracy is the gap between those at the
top and those at the bottom.
Not because I'm against making money, I'm
actually very interested in it.
I think capitalism is the greatest system
we've ever—has ever been invented.
But like every other system, if you have no
rules, the whole system collapses and it very
nearly did in 2008.
So if we're going to have a system where it's
possible to make large amounts of money, which
it is, which I think is a good thing, we've
got to have a system where everybody believes
that it works for them.
And that's the danger to this country right
now.
Eighty percent of the people in this country
have not seen a raise for the last twenty
years.
Almost all the wealth that's been accumulated
in this country, particularly coming out of
this recession, has gone to the top 20 percent.
Now the - I don't have a problem with people
being rich and people not being rich.
I do have a problem with people not affording
the basic necessities, which we've more or
less fixed in this country for—basically.
We'd have arguments with some of my more liberal
friends about that.
What I have a problem with is if 80 percent
of the people, the system—believe the system
doesn't work for them.
It doesn't matter if you argue that it does
work for them, because if they believe it
doesn't, the whole system is dead.
That would be a terrible shame for this extraordinary
country that we've built over the last 235
years.
So I think a—some sort of minimal standard
of living.
I was the first governor in the country, by
two weeks, beating Tommy Thompson by two weeks,
which I'm thrilled to say, who did welfare
reform.
Why did we do welfare reform?
Because I fundamentally believe you shouldn't
get something for nothing, unless you really
are disabled.
That's not the same as saying there shouldn't
be some kind of minimal standard where everybody
can participate.
The reason that healthcare costs have been
so outrageous and the Medicare projections,
as Grover pointed out, are so outrageous has
very little to do with Medicare.
It has to do with the fact that the healthcare
industry is completely out of control.
Why?
Because the economics doesn't work and why
is that?
Because you pay me to do as much stuff as
I possibly can to you, whether it works or
not.
There's no other system in the world that
works like that.
You've got to have a basic fee-per-patient
system.
If you keep paying me to do stuff, I'm going
to keep doing it to you.
And that's why the medical costs have gone
up at three times the rate of inflation.
The reason Medicare is out of control is not
because Medicare is a bad program, it's because
healthcare costs are out of control and we
have to be serious about dealing with healthcare
costs.
So I—I defend this system of basically a
minimal standard of living.
Healthcare came in under Johnson because healthcare
costs were driving older people not to be
able to be adequately taken care of.
Life expectancy's gone up dramatically.
I won't claim it's only because of Medicare,
but that certainly had a lot to do with it.
Medicaid has turned out to be the most effective
way of expanding access to healthcare.
We used it twenty years ago in my state and
every kid in my state under eighteen has had
health insurance for twenty years.
So I am a—I am not a person who believes
we ought to keep spending more money on social
programs and I agree in principle with the
dilemma that Grover laid out.
We've got to deal with this stuff.
We have a—a budget problem that isn't going
to go away unless we make some fundamental
changes.
But I'm not philosophically interested in
dismantling the Great Society.
HIRSH: Just before I let Grover respond to
that, I just wanted to follow up.
I mean what you laid out, all the problems
we're dealing with today, starting with inequality,
poverty, I mean doesn't that mean that the
Great Society failed in the end if it just...
DEAN: No, it means that—it means that the
rules of capitalism have been skewed.
If you look at what von Hayek actually wrote,
the penalty in a capitalist society for making
big mistakes has to be failure.
We don't have that penalty in this country.
This is what Elizabeth Warren's talking about.
I think that conservatives ought to love Elizabeth
Warren.
It's perfectly plain to me, not because I'm
an Elizabeth Warren liberal, or you can call
me whatever you want.
It's perfectly plain to me that if you have
ten or fifeen or twenty institutions around
the world that, if they fail, the entire western
economic system collapses that you have no
choice but to bail them out, unpopular as
that was.
If you don't bail them out we all go back
to living in conditions that were before the
Great Depression, which includes some people
in this room who are reasonably well off,
as happened in the Great Depression.
So you either have to have a lot of regulation,
which I'm not that crazy about, or you have
to have rules in capitalism which let capitalism
really work.
And capitalism hasn't worked as well as it
could have.
It has worked well enough to lift this country
to the—the highest standard of living, essentially,
in the world, if you adjust for demography
and so forth and so on.
But it hasn't worked well enough so that we've
taken the kinks out of it, so there can be
adequate distribution of wealth.
We're not talking about socialism or making
sure everybody pays a 90 percent tax rate,
as they did when LBJ was president.
We know that doesn't work.
But what I do believe is that in a capitalist
society there have to be rules so that everybody
has some skin in the game and some investment
in making capitalism succeed and that's the
danger I see in this country.
HIRSH: Grover.
NORQUIST: Yeah.
You sound, in defending these programs, that
we're going to fix them, like my Republican
friends who say "The Iraq war wasn't a mistake,
but we're never doing that again'" And I think
you have to go back and look at the damage
that these programs did.
They made things worse than they would have
been, OK?
They took half of the government over—today.
Social Security, for instance, if—this was
not an idea out of Kansas.
It's an idea out of Germany.
Social Security was thought up by our friend
who unified the German state.
And the whole—his project, it doesn't transfer
well over here.
Social Security isn't an investment program.
We're now, today, in the states and private
sector's almost all shifted over, with the
exception of some unionized companies, from
defined benefit plans to defined contribution
plans, 401ks, IRAs.
And if you don't have that you do end up with
people making all sorts of commitments into
the future and the workers get screwed and
the companies go bankrupt and consumers get
cheated.
And the private sector has largely shifted
that over.
We're—now we're going state and moving from
defined benefit plans, where politicians would
promise you the world today, because by the
time you collect an uncollectable and unpayable
pension, because it's promising more than
the government's willing to take, I'll be
dead or out of office and it's somebody else's
problem.
So states—Utah's completely shifted over
to defined contribution.
A number of other states, Michigan, at the
state level, completely shifted over back
in 1990 and more and more states are moving
in that direction.
Had we done Social Security that way, we wouldn't
have a $10 trillion unfunded liability.
If you fixed—Ryan and—Congressman Ryan
and Senator Sununu put forward a plan that
the Social Security actuary went and rated.
And he said look, if you'd phased in allowing
you to take your FICA taxes and putting them
in a 401k that you control and people over
fifty-five stay in the old system, everybody
else moves over to the new one, by 2024, we'd
have $7 trillion in those accounts.
Why do we have inequality of wealth in this
country?
Because we take the income that low-income
people and young people make and we take it
in Social Security taxes and we tell you it's
savings, but it's not.
If it was savings, low-income people would
actually have savings.
They'd have a resource to share with their
family.
They would be able to handle those and $7
trillion, fairly evenly spread out across
the country, so the Social Security that everybody's
in, would dramatically change the inequality
that, in terms of wealth accumulation in this
country, Social Security created and made
possible and made it difficult for people
to save for their future, particularly—I
mean, rich people can save for their future,
but low-income people find that Social Security
takes their money and they can't.
And by the way, you could not only do that,
but drop the FICA tax from what would be 20
percent if nothing was done, down to five
percent in order to deal with disability and
some of the non-saving portions of Social
Security.
If we look at Medicaid, if we block-granted
that to the states, as we have done with Aid
to Families of Dependent Children, I know—under
Clinton, Clinton did this.
I know that the left says the world would
end.
Well, they all said that when—when Clinton
signed the third bill that the Republicans
passed to move Aid to Families with Dependent
Children, now TANF, out to the states, so
you have fifty states trying fifty different
things.
What—what our friends at the state have
missed is that one of the reasons governments
don't do very—governments can blow things
up, but they're not very good at creating
wealth.
They—or creating new innovations going into
the future.
And the reason is, by definition, they're
a monopoly.
The advantage of states over the federal government,it's
not this 'closer to the people' stuff.
I'm not any closer to the mayor of D.C. than
I am to the president of the United States,
in terms of being able to call him on the
phone and suggest something.
But there are fifty states—some say fifty-seven,
but at least fifty and they can take different
approaches and this is why I think it's very
important that we allow the fifty states to
take different approaches and let's find out
what works.
And I think it's obvious that defined contribution
pensions are better than defined benefit pensions,
in terms of being stable and creating wealth
for all Americans, not just the Kennedys and
the Rockefellers.
And that's the missed opportunity.
The number of heads of households, people
who are out of work because of these programs
are devastating there.
But what Social Security has done in replacing
savings and telling poor and middle-income
people you can't save because we're taking
your money, promising you it's being saved
in West Virginia somewhere, but it's not,
has created tremendous inequality and the
fact that we have very bad job creation in
this country.
That's one of the reasons why low-income people
are not doing better.
We need to be having more jobs.
HIRSH: Brief—very briefly, before we go
to...
DEAN: OK, so here's the central dilemma of
the argument that we're having, what do you
do about the outliers?
So in the—in the case of Social Security
and defined contribution, I'm not unwilling
to look at that, but the problem is what do
you do about the people who are taken advantage
of or end up in some investment scheme.
We know there were a lot of people who lost
their IRAs in—in the 2008 recession, because
of a lot of the chicanery on Wall Street and
some of it was just bad luck.
Or maybe they just made bad investment decisions
and they don't have an IRA.
What do they retire on if there's nothing
to fall back on?
And what is our obligation to keep them from
starving?
Do we have one?
Same is true of states.
Texas is my—my favorite example.
Lot of people moving into Texas, Texas' economy
doing really great.
Twenty-two percent of the kids, in spite of
CHIP, have no health insurance in the state
of Texas, 22 percent.
Now those are American kids, not just Texan
kids.
I think I have a responsibility for those
kids as an American.
So the question is, in this, in this area
where every—everything has devolved and
everything is—is let's let the states, what
about the people who screw up and what about
the kids who don't get health insurance?
What obligation do we have as a nation to
those children?
So I think it's easy to say oh, well let's
decentralize.
Let's have defined contributions.
There are situations we have to talk about
and you have to deal with.
We have to define our responsibility for each
other.
What is it?
Do we have any?
Because I think if we don't, we're not a nation.
We're certainly not going to be a great nation.
The last point I want to make is I would disagree
with the idea that we don't foster innovation
or anything.
You know how we foster innovation and wealth
creation in this country?
I agree, the government doesn't do it.
No, I don't agree with that.
We do it because we provide the absolutely
essential creative framework, which is the
rule of law.
That is the great genius of American and the
great genius of our constitution.
We don't do the innovation.
We set a—a—we set forth a table that millions
and millions of people come to this country
to do their innovation, because we have a
predictable rule of law.
And that, we need to focus on.
What the rule of law says is that the table
is level for everybody, whether you're rich
or poor or in between, no matter what your
circumstances are, if you're willing to work
hard and play by the rules, you can make a
lot of money and do well.
If we lose that and if we lose people believing
that, then that's when we're in trouble.
Right now, I don't think we're in trouble.
We've got some things to do.
Financially, we've got a lot of work to do.
We got to make some tough decisions.
I think the fundamental nature of this country
is still sound.
NORQUIST: But I think in the spirit—in the
spirit of bipartisanship, I agree there's
a role for the government in providing rule
of law and protecting property rights and
right of contracts so that people don't cheat
each other.
HIRSH: Let's open it up to Q&A.
Please wait for the microphone to come to
you and stand and state your name and affiliation
and try to keep things as concise as possible.
We have less than a half an hour for this.
Yes, sir, right over here.
QUESTION: Chris Broughton, Millennium Challenge
Corporation.
Great discussion, gentlemen, thank you for
being with us here today.
First, I want to start with a quote of Paul—by
Paul Krugman, "the United States government
is turning into an insurance company with
a standing army".
The second piece is really political.
It's the political challenge that we—don't
think we delved into enough about tackling
entitlements, which both of you I think recognize
the fiscal threat to you and it's really the
NIMBY problem, which is general used in environmental
terms, but not—"not in my benefit yo", you
might say in the entitlements context.
So the first piece of that is there've been
lots of proposal, Bowles-Simpson, Rivlin,
et cetera.
None of them have moved forward.
There's also the element that when we think
about those entitlements, it's actually a
resource transfer from blue states to red
states.
I'm getting to my question.
I'm going quick.
HIRSH: Good.
QUESTION: So the first is how do you tackle
the entitlement problem?
And it's both a red state and a blue state.
Everyone benefits, right?
And - and—and the second piece of it is
it's also structural to the United States
economy, right?
So, Grover, you were talking about the comparison
to the Great Society and conditions then and
now and—and—and the role of entitlements
in that.
But one could argue it's actually more just
the structure of the economy, globalization,
mechanization, shift from manufacturing services,
has far more to do than—than the entitlement
programs in terms of the structure of jobs
and employment and so forth.
So how do you think about those, both the
political problem and also the structure of
the economy?
Thank you.
NORQUIST: Look, you—when you said...I would
argue that these programs have made the situation
worse, not better, because there were alternatives—ways
to spend those resources.
It could have been done, in some cases, with
fifty states competing to do it differently.
I realize that the modern Democratic Party
does not like the idea of allowing states
to make these decisions, because, as you look
at it, there are twenty-four states with a
Republican governor, Republican House and
Republican Senate.
This is shortly after the election, when the
New York Times announced the modern Republican
Party had ceased to exist in the world.
And there are now seven states that Democrats
run completely.
Half the country lives under a Republican
governance and one-third of that—one-sixth
lives in—under Democratic governance.
If you look at the blue—the blue states,
their statespeople tend to leave and the red
states, their statespeople either have been
moving, too, for a while or continuing to
move to.
So we—we can tell what works and what doesn't.
That's why I suggest that when we discuss
what's going to work and what doesn't, we
take a look in two years and four years and
six years, because these red states are staying
red for the rest of the decade and the blue
states staying blue for the rest of the decade
and maybe another ten years.
And we will actually have a—a controlled
experiment.
Had this conversation with a nice lady who
runs the Nation magazine and she turned green,
because she doesn't think that if you take
her ideas and you do them in a state it'll
work.
Really stupid ideas can only be done at the
national level.
If you have...
(LAUGHTER)
... you have a really stupid idea and you
do it in Massachusetts, like government-run
healthcare under Dukakis and then the repealed
it as soon as he lost the presidential election,
because it was just for show.
We're not going to live under this.
You can't do that in a state.
Vermont just went through a similar conversation
about government-controlled healthcare.
So there's a reason why fifty states are better
than a federal government for looking at these
sorts of projects.
And even better is 300 million Americans minding
their own business, doing their own stuff.
HIRSH: Thank you, Mr. Jefferson.
Yes.
DEAN: I—I—I...
NORQUIST: There's nothing old about the idea
of the Constitution.
DEAN: I do like the quote from Paul Krugman,
which I hadn't heard, even though it is a
bit of a unrelated, it reminds me of John
McCain's quote about Russia, a—"a gas station
posing as a country."
I mean, I—I don't like talking in sound
bites and I really don't like Washington talking
point speaking-ese, but when you get a really
good one, you just got to repeat it.
(LAUGHTER)
Look, I think we do need changes in entitlements.
And the question is how can we make this—this—these
programs survive?
I've already talked about why I'm not supportive
particularly of giving the states more flexibility.
I was when I was governor.
I was the head of the National Governor's
Association, but I've since—Texas has really
just thrown me for a loop.
Here's a state with rising economy that's
bragged about by its governor, which not only
has 22 percent of all its children with no
health insurance, they're 48th in the country
in terms of educational achievement in high
school.
I mean I—I—I don't—we can't risk having
the third—second—third largest state in
the country—second largest state in the
country, population-wise.
We can't risk having that many people get
out of high school who are ignorant.
And so just think there is a federal interest
in making sure there's a minimum level of—I
support the common core.
I don't—I have some problems with some of
the testing.
Maybe we can look at that.
The idea that nine times nine is something
other than eighty-one in states if they choose
not to test for it is insane.
Mississippi used to dumb down their tests
to make sure that an adequate number of people
passed it to satisfy the Department of Education.
This is crazy.
We are one country and if we're not one big
country, we're not going to be the most powerful
country in the face of the Earth.
Part of the reason we're as powerful as we
are is because we have 310 million people
that can generate wealth for common cause
among the fifty states.
So I—I just think this notion—I'm very
willing to look at the federal programs and
see if they can't be changed.
I supported the sequester.
The reason I supported the sequester was because
I thought that no way was anybody ever going
to make those cuts if they had to vote on
them.
I'm serious about budget cutting.
But I'm not serious if we can all punt and
hope that somebody at the local level—what
makes you think that the local government
is any more effective than federal government?
We get madder at the federal government, but,
you know, I've seen the legislature in some
of these places.
NORQUIST: Because—because you can leave.
HIRSH: Yeah, there's an argument for accountability
there.
Let's—let's go to...
NORQUIST: I'm sorry, one second.
Krugman was wrong.
I—I—I really apologize for not pointing
out...when I quoted Krugman, I failed to point
out that he was wrong.
The fed—the federal government is a Ponzi
scheme for the standing army, not an insurance
company.
HIRSH: OK, very good.
Let's go to...
(LAUGHTER)
Let's go to a question over here, Mike Haltzel.
Please be succinct.
QUESTION: Yeah, thank you.
I'm Mike Haltzel from Johns Hopkins.
Guys, terrific discussion.
Look, the one thing we haven't—that you
folks really haven't done very much is put
the foreign in the Council on Foreign Relations.
I'd—unless we think we live on an island
and other people's experiences are completely
irrelevant, and I don't think either one of
you think so, I think we have to look at it.
I love my country, Mr. Dean, as much as anybody
and we're successful in many ways.
But we're not so successful in many ways,
whether it's life expectancy or infant mortality
or—or scores of our—of our students.
You can argue about how that's—you know,
there are some variables there, but the fact
is we're not perfect.
You talk about Social Security, you alluded
to Bismarck and said it's just not transferrable.
It—it strikes me, we're—the last time
I looked at OECD statistics, we were the third-lowest
taxed of all the thirty-four—I think Mexico
and Chile were taxed lower than we were.
So the vast majority are taxed more and yet
these countries that tax more and presumably
redistribute more have better—I'll use the
value word, distribution of wealth than we
do, yet you're saying we ought to go the other
direction.
I just don't understand that.
And—and so, my question—I'll just stop
and say could you both maybe discuss a little
bit about international comparisons?
And I'm saying this, I—I know at a time
when Europe's having problems, so I lead with
my chin, but that's largely because of...
HIRSH: Let's—let's go to that, yeah, particularly
since the President, in his speech last night,
I think made a big point of saying, you know,
we're—we may not be great, but we're doing
better than everyone else.
NORQUIST: Yeah, look, our government sucks
less than all the others.
(LAUGHTER)
And I think we should be proud of that.
HIRSH: End the discussion right.
NORQUIST: Our government...
(LAUGHTER)
It is a matter of patriotic honesty to point
that this government, for all its failures,
is less horrible and is less destructive of
economic growth and human happiness than most
other governments you can think of in the
world throughout history, if not all, OK.
And the problem is it could be all net positive.
It doesn't have to have all of the negatives.
We've made some real positive.
We've cut but we have a lot more to do.
Europe is saddled with a VAT, which is the
difference between the United States—Europe
is the United States plus a VAT.
Each country is about that much bigger a state
than ours.
People—trust people.
People move to Texas, oh, Texas is no good.
Well, you can take a look at it if you—not
mentioned is Texas is a high immigrant state.
Immigrants in Texas test better than immigrants
in other places, as does everybody else.
But they have more of the immigrants and they
don't test as well as other guys.
But if you're doing apples to apples on immigrants
and so on, you are getting—Texas does a
better job of educating them than other states.
If you're from really close to the Canadian
border, as Moynihan pointed out, things can
be different.
But if you want to do apples to apples on—on
how well states are doing, the fact that people
move there from other states tells you something
about how—what people thinks works and what
it doesn't.
Same thing with people coming to the United
States.
Europe does not do immigration very well.
That's why they're the past and we're the
future.
China and Japan don't do immigration well.
They're going to have real problems maintaining
the sort of social welfare transfers as they
get older, before they get rich, as they have
declining—continuing declining labor forces
and ours can be expanding as much as we want
to.
HIRSH: So let—Governor—Governor, do you—do—do
you agree that...
DEAN: I think it's—I think it's—the point
is well taken.
I deeply appreciate that question.
Let's look at what we do well and what the
Europeans do well.
They have a much higher index of—of wealth
equality, if you'll say that.
And it is borne out of the fact that education
levels and borne out of infant mortality.
It's even borne out of happiness measure,
however that—even I will admit that's a
little squishy soft social science.
And they have more redistribution of wealth.
So they do some things very well and some
things not so well.
I think this is a much more dynamic economy.
The Europeans know that.
I'm fascinated by the German economy.
You know, we have labor problems here from
time to time.
France has labor problems here from time to
time.
Germany mostly doesn't.
Why?
Because they have a model for integrating
unions and investor—and investors in corporations,
which I think is the envy of the world and
we ought to adopt it here.
We can learn from Europe: Europe can lean
from us.
I was in Europe not long ago and I was scheduled
to come home on a Lufthansa flight and I was
told, "oh my God, there's going to be a Lufthansa
strike in the next days" and I was leaving
the day after, so I'm in a panic.
I don't know what to do.
I'm sure the airport is going to be a disaster.
Oh no, they only go on strike for one day,
because they—when they get serious in the
labor negotiations, that's how they let the
management know they're very upset.
I mean, so no productivity was lost.
Lufthansa didn't use—lose a bundle of money
and the labor unions realized that that was
to their advantage too, because they could
get more if the company did better.
I mean we need to start looking at European
models.
The—I—one of the fool—most foolish things
Mitt Romney said last timein a long list,
was that—was we don't want to be like Europe.
We don't want to be like Europe and we're
not Europe.
And I absolutely agree that they have done
a lousy job integrating immigrants and—and
they're paying a huge price for that now.
And we struggle with that.
We do better than anybody else in—on the
face of the earth.
But there are some things over there—we
ought not to blanketly dismiss everything
they do in Europe, because there are some
things they do, particularly the things that
result in the indicators that you just talked
about, and labor relations, which we could
learn a lot from and we should learn a lot
from, because it would make our economy stronger.
HIRSH: Let's go back to this side of the room,
if there are any questions on this side of
the room.
Gentleman right over there.
QUESTION: Yeah, Ted Alden from the Council
on Foreign Relations.
Wanted to push a little harder on the defined
contribution idea, because I think in—in
the private sector, in a lot of ways it's
worked well.
It's better for the companies in terms of
cost control.
For people who are paying into the plans,
market returns have been pretty good.
But we know that most people are not saving
nearly enough for retirement: certainly not
putting aside enough money to ensure any kind
of security in retirement.
Why is that going to work better on the Social
Security side?
Are you—are you talking about a sort of
mandated contribution?
Everybody's going to have to do this and it's
going to be managed privately.
How do you prevent people from not looking
after their own futures, in effect, in the
way they ought to.
NORQUIST: Yeah, I think when—that all the
plans that are talking about reforming Social
Security along the Chilean model or some others,
would take the present amount of money the
government takes from you and gives to somebody
in Wyoming next week and instead requires
you to take that same amount of money and
put it into a 401k for yourself.
So the reason people don't save enough is
that the—the government lies to you and
tells you it's doing the saving for you.
And so that kind of Ponzi scheme displaces
real savings and so I think that's one of
the great things that we could get the government
to stop doing.
It's not a good idea for the government to
lie to people.
It's not a good idea to steal their money.
It's not a good idea to tell them there's
money when it's not there.
The idea that somebody might cheat you, when
the guy talking to you has a $10 trillion
dollar present value of its unfunded liabilities
or $25 trillion to $35 trillion on Medicare.
What?
You're not allowed to be part of the conversation
if you've stolen $10 trillion or $25 trillion,
$35 trillion from people and told them that
they were going to get it back when they're
not, under this Ponzi scheme that they've
set up.
Let's cut our losses on that, take care of
the people that the government lied to.
Let's us be honest with the older people and
everybody under fifty-five let's move over
and give them that opportunity.
And yeah, I would—I do think that it would
pay, at least at the beginning, as you move
forward, to require at least until they've
saved up to a certain amount of money that
they could be sure to take care of themselves
in case of an accident or old age that they
could do that.
(CROSSTALK)
NORQUIST: One second.
When I look at the German workforce, I include
the Turks.
So people that talk about how happy they are
I think should include everybody in Germany,
not just some.
DEAN: So I have a—just a quick question
for you about how you would handle the question
of people who, for whatever reason, don't
save enough, whether they get screwed by a
Bernie Madoff or whether they didn't save
enough and it was their own fault.
So what do you do and what's our responsibility
in a defined contribution program for the
failures?
NORQUIST: Well, I think two things.
It—the—in terms of having a safety net
for somebody gets wiped out by something,
I think you can look at that when you're talking
about one or two percent of the population
or a fraction, and somebody could do the calculation
on what percentage of 401ks have turned out
to be fraudulent.
When you're comparing that with 100 percent
rate of fraud under the government program,
it seems to me from going from 100 percent
to 1 percent and you go, hey wait, there's
1 percent here.
We've been fifty years with 100 percent.
I think that there should be a little sense
of humility on the part of the government
who did that.
And this bifurcation of Vietnam and the Great
Society strikes me as—as a nice trick, but
it doesn't work.
The same—you should read that speech that
Johnson gave.
We're going to have smart people get together
in a room and make these decisions on your
life and so on.
That included the draft.
That included Vietnam.
It was just the whiz kids.
They weren't whiz kids who did this.
The whiz kids did Vietnam.
You know, I mean the same...
(CROSSTALK)
NORQUIST: ...the same government hubris leads
to...
(CROSSTALK)
DEAN: OK.
Let me just insert one...
(CROSSTALK)
DEAN: ... one line.
HIRSH: Very quickly.
DEAN: All I did was ask one question to get
that response, so I—you know, right now
the fraud rate in Social Security is zero
percent.
NORQUIST: From the government.
They promised there's $10 trillion they've
promised you that isn't there.
That's the fraud.
DEAN: So far—so far, every single person
has been paid.
Now we can argue about what's going to happen
in the future, but to say that Social Security
is 100 percent fraud is, it's very funny and
amusing but it's certainly not true.
HIRSH: I'm glad that we brought it back to...
NORQUIST: The—the—the—the—if—if
the guy—the guy who runs a Ponzi scheme,
if Madoff had said oh no, I'll get you eventually,
I promise.
He hadn't cheated anyone until it got caught.
Everybody'd got paid up to a certain point.
HIRSH: Government—government as Bernie Madoff.
Let's go back over here.
And I—and I'm glad that we brought it back,
Grover, a little bit to the legacy of the
Great Society itself, because I would like
to try to finish up on that.
Yes, sir.
QUESTION: Hi.
Scott Moore.
I'm an international affairs fellow here with
the Council.
So I appreciate that this debate has revolved
quite a bit around evidence.
I—I feel the need to point out, though,
the case against the Great Society relies
on trying to prove a counterfactual here.
We don't know what would have happened without
the Great Society.
And to return to a previous question, which
I think was very important, if we look around
the world, we tend to see that some of the
most effective social spending programs are
forms of conditional cash transfers, which,
if I'm not mistaken, would be typically derided
here in the United States as handouts.
So my question is, do we—do we really have
the courage to have this debate about the
evidence and what works and what doesn't?
Thank you.
DEAN: I hope we do and there's a fascinating
article, which I think actually may have been
in Foreign Affairs, I can't honestly remember.
But it was about six or eight months ago,
about a project in Kenya, which—in which
the—the donor organization just gave cash
to people, with no accountability.
And they did that because our USAID model
is a great organization, but it fundamentally
makes people more dependent, not less dependent.
And they just decided to experiment.
And it turned out that people used it to improve
their lives and their productivity.
I—they did not go out and spend it on drugs
and gambling and all that good business.
They went out and put a new roof on their
house or educated their children.
So it's a fascinating question.
I think you'd have a really tough time, from
a political point of view, trying to convince
either American congresspeople or their people
who they represent that this was a great idea
and we ought to—ought to switch over any
family support to a system like that, because
I think you'd get the same kind of stuff about
now that you're drug testing and all this
other business.
But we ought to be fooling around with ideas
like that and see what works and what doesn't,
because right now, I would never argue that
we couldn't improve.
And there is some field work that, in fact,
shows you that outlandish—what appear to
be outlandish ideas, which I would have thought
was outlandish until I read the research,
turns out to be not such an outlandish idea
and it's worth pursuing.
NORQUIST: But remember, one of us up here
says "let's have fifty experiments".
I'm willing to have real experience and compare.
The status position of well, we're going to
try things, but the federal government will
make one big lurch in this direction for fifty
years and that won't work.
They'll be another big lurch in that direction.
Governments don't react very rapidly.
Governments have moved to defined contribution
slowly, OK.
And that's—it's not a liberal idea, by the
way.
I mean the—the new lady governor from Rhode
Island, I'm sorry.
I don't remember her name, but she did significant
reform on their pension, defeated the unions
in the primary and one in the general.
San Jose, left of center Mayor, similar reforms.
OK, this—these New Deal, Great Society programs
are crowding out all the resources that I
think should be in people's hands and the
liberals think that they'd like to spend,
but they first have to pry it out of—of—of
those programs.
I think we ought to have competition among
the ideas and, yes, let's look at Europe.
I mean I think we have a lot to look at Europe.
When people talk about the United States as
unique, they're usually talking about good
things, OK.
Like not having the government run the steel
mills or not having a draft, usually.
But we're the—we're the country with the
dumbest tort laws in the world and we should
look at Europe and—and other countries.
We should look at Sweden for school choice.
We could look—look at Sweden for their policies
on—on the death tax, like not having one.
So there are a lot of things that Europe does
well.
There's a reason it's standing.
The reason Scandinavian countries are still
there with high tax rates, they do a bunch
of stuff well.
We should do that and pass on the things they
do less well.
HIRSH: Very interesting, some areas of agreement
here.
Let's take just a couple more.
Yes, sir.
Please stand and say your name...
QUESTION: Nick Eberstadt, American Enterprise
Institute.
Governor, since the fraud word came up and
since you're a medical doctor, I wanted to
ask you about the disability programs.
When you as a doctor see that more people
are getting disability payments than working
in the manufacturing sector, when you see
that the healthiest generation of American
workers in history is also the officially
most disabled, how do you respond to that?
How do you think that through?
DEAN: I'm—I'm willing to evaluate programs.
What I'm not willing to do is do what the
Republicans just voted to do in the house,
which is to blindly cut stuff without knowing
what you're talking about.
If there's a big disconnect between, OK, there's
problems in the disability program and then,
OK, so we're not going to transfer $32 billion
to support the program.
I think it would be nice to actually have
some evidentiary data and some thoughtful
look at what needs to be done.
Nobody should be in favor of people getting
something for nothing.
It's not only bad for the country and the
taxpayers, it's really bad for the people
who are getting the something-for-nothing,
which is why I was interested in welfare reform.
On the other hand, I think this blind sort
of attacking this welfare queen pink Cadillac
stuff is incredibly destructive.
It's foolish and what it does is put the other
side, which is me, on the defensive so we—we
instinctively resist all the reforms.
Why not have a discussion before we start
dropping legislation like that and then try
to come to some sort of an agreement?
I think we could agree that there might be
people on disability that don't really need
to be there.
I think the solution is probably not cutting
the living hell out of the whole program,
so that—that—let's just say the 90 percent
of the people who do need to be there are
getting 18 percent less.
That's the kind of policy—the problem that
we have in this town and in this country right
now is that nobody wants to look at the middle
and acknowledge that the other side might
be right about part of the issue and they
have—do the same for you.
NORQUIST: I—let me just promise on Boehner's
behalf that if a Democrat comes up with a
piece of legislation that moves in that direction,
I think we could get a vote on it in the House.
But when the other team puts out nothing to—and
then criticize the Republicans for not doing
it differently, I think you then have to say
where is the Democratic Party's willingness
to have any reforms at all?
We've had six years without reforms and the
next two years is evidently fantasyland.
And I think it would pay to have a Democratic
Party that is, at the national level, looking
at reforms.
At some states and some local governments,
San Jose, Rhode Island, we're seeing those
reforms at the state level.
Why?
Because states live another—next to other
states and they have to behave or everybody
does leave.
HIRSH: Just one more quick question and then
we're going to have to finish up.
Yes, ma'am.
QUESTION: Thank you.
Esther Brimmer now at George Washington University.
I'd like to go back to the foreign policy
case for actually being one society.
The real legacy of the Great Society is not
all the—only the specific programs which
we've been talking about today.
It's the idea that we are one country and
that we're responsible for ourselves as an
entire country and that everybody's life in
this country matters.
So it seem to me when we think about the foreign
policy case that not only do we need, in the
21st century, a society where no one is hungry,
everyone gets an adequate education because
innovation comes from everywhere, and that
everybody is able to participate in a—an
economy which would—gives them an equal
chance to get to the starting line.
That's what makes us a great country.
Ultimately, in the 21st century, we will need
not only a great economy and a great military,
but the power of attraction has made the rest
of the world want to follow the United States.
That's the legacy of the Great Society.
Thank you.
HIRSH: Any—any final thoughts on that?
NORQUIST: Yeah.
That's the legacy of America's success is,
the Great Society impeded that, slowed it
down and damaged it, didn't help.
We are the country that people want to model
ourselves off and that is, as the governor
said, providing the rule of law and providing
an opportunity where people are safe.
Nobody comes and steals your stuff or hits
you on the head and, other than that, leaves
you alone.
I worry a little bit about this 'one society'
thing.
Really?
What religion are we all going to be?
You know, what do you mean, one society?
I—I—when the government decides—again,
read this Lyndon Johnson thing.
He's going to worry about our soul.
He's going to worry about our walking out
in the—in—in the fields.
He's going to worry about our leisure time,
the government's going to get involved it.
You know, I think the government can and should
protect everybody and—from—from getting
hurt by somebody else or robbed by somebody
else, protect their house from being broken
into or—or their car.
But after that, they should leave people alone
and the challenge is, the government has done
so many things, it's become damaging to human
program progress, slowing economic growth.
I mean this is a very, very—I passed this
out, but this is the difference between the
Reagan growth from when—from depths of the
recession, and the Obama growth from the depths
of the recession.
This is 10 million jobs.
This is a lot of income and wealth that middle-income
people don't have.
Ten million people are not going to be the
Rockefellers, OK.
There's going to be 10 million people getting
their first job or getting a job that they
don't have now.
The damage done by these bad policies—these
destructive policies compared to Reagan's,
are 10 million households where dad or mom
doesn't have...
(CROSSTALK)
HIRSH: Governor Dean, you have the final word.
NORQUIST: ... a job.
HIRSH: Final word, very briefly.
DEAN: I would agree with Esther.
I think the key to the Great Society—we
didn't spend a lot of time on this, was in
fact the notion of getting everybody to the
starting line.
There was a whole percent of the population
who were not only not at the starting line,
but they weren't allowed to vote.
And I think everybody has to fully participate.
And fully participating, this is where I—this
is where I am not a libertarian.
Full participation is not 'OK, everybody gets
to vote'.
Full participation is you have a decent school
system in your neighborhood that's just as
good as the school system in my neighborhood.
Full participation is—is you—your kids
get to go to college, just like mine get to
go to college.
Otherwise, you're not at the starting line.
And when you can't get to the starting line,
you never get to the finish line.
The genius of this country is, in fact, a
lot of ability to do for yourself and work
hard to succeed.
But if you can't get everybody to the starting
line then you can't succeed.
And the reason for that is, going back to
what I said about income inequality.
When enough people can't get to the starting
line then they stop believing in the vision
of the country.
That is why the Great Society was important,
because it was about getting people to the
starting line.
HIRSH: (inaudible)
(CROSSTALK)
NORQUIST: That was the goal.
The reality was the opposite.
(APPLAUSE)
HIRSH: And the debate over the Great Society
lives on, clearly.
Thank you very much.
I want to remind everyone that this has been
on the record.
Thank you, gentlemen, for a very enlightening
(inaudible).
NORQUIST: You kept talking about...
END